dans le petit matin ses élèves attendent
le bus qui les emmènera au collège de
montsauche à 20 km d'ici cet arrêt est
le seul de ce hameau d'aligner un enfant
alors certains parents sont venus
déposer leurs enfants en voiture car
tous n'habite pas à proximité
ma fille est obligé de faire donc à
km900 tout seul sans trottoirs sans
lumière l'hiver la nuit tombe de bonheur
donc ma taille soir elle sera dans le
noir et à l'époque pour dit on peut pas
laisser les enfants seuls quoi j'ai mon
enfant qui va au collège et qui est
obligé de faire un kilomètre 300 à pied
dans les mêmes conditions et malgré que
le bus passe à proximité et ma fille par
en revanche qui est encore en primaire
le bus s'arrête à la porte
même s'ils passent devant certaines
maisons impossible pour le chauffeur de
s'arrêter
or des arts et sécurisé prévu par son
itinéraire maintenant le système mobigo
donc on est vraiment tenu de respecter
les horaires les emplacements d'arrêt on
peut pas pour des ouais je sais qu'ici
il ya un problème tu es plus loin qui
est pas au même arrêt mais bon après
c'est moi sommes jeunes pop sur
plusieurs arrêts mais le problème après
c'est des histoires d'assurance les
parents et les élus locaux demandent
donc à la région en charge du transport
la création de nouveaux arrêts et plus
de souplesse dans l'établissement des
circuits on propose que les clés le
ramassage chic et des arrêts qui soit
fait à l'heure pas systématique mais
réorganiser un peu les arrêts dans les
hameaux parce qu'on a 70% de la
population qui habite dans les amants
aussi pour parler des gens qui habitent
dans le bourg il y en a très peu donc et
nous en tant qu'élu on est d'accord s'il
ya sur coup de payer
interrogé par nos soins le conseil
régional précise avoir reçu 33 demandes
de création d'art et dans le secteur en
dehors des délais prévus des dossiers en
cours d'examen depuis le retour des
vacances
une réunion devrait ensuite être
organisée avec les élus et les parents
pour clarifier la situation